hi Donald John Trump do solemnly swear
that I will faithfully execute that I
will faithfully execute the office of
President of the United States the
office of President of the United States
and will to the best of my ability and
will to the best of my ability preserve
protect and defend preserve protect and
defend the Constitution of the United
States the Constitution of the United
States so help me God so help me God
congratulations mr. president Donald
Trump becomes the 45th president of the
United States the nation he takes over
is deeply divided something he seems to
realize a new national pride will stare
ourselves lift our sights and heal our
divisions it's time to remember that old
wisdom our soldiers will never forget
that whether we are black or brown or
white we all bleed the same red blood of
patriots he had a message to for the
rest of the world we will seek
friendship and goodwill with the nations
of the world but we do so with the
understanding that it is the right of
all nations to put their own interests
first we do not seek to impose our way
of life on anyone but rather to let it
shine as an example we will shine for
everyone to follow on the National Mall
hundreds of thousands of people to cheer
or simply to witness a historic moment
[Music]
freshen the new job Trump was sitting
behind the presidential resolute desk in
the Oval Office he signed his first
executive order on Obamacare the aim to
minimize the economic burden of his
predecessors signature health care law
he also signed formal nominations
members of the new administration a new
administration a new direction and a new
America leaving some hopeful others
fearful
[Music]